[Music]
hey
look who's here everyone applause
you think you're important i was
referencing the g fuel
yeah say something funny
today we're gonna do something
incredibly funny and hysterical
we're gonna react to my old videos
again it's edgar's favorite pastime the
other day
i heard some giggling next to me it was
my [ __ ] and she was watching these type
of videos
i didn't know this was the thing i don't
know whether to be flattered or annoyed
but someone made a compilation of every
time i struggled with words
i don't understand how that can be a
compilation don't actually
if it's html or whatever they probably
don't actually put
you
i better get there what was i trying to
say yeah it happened sometimes i start
on what i can't video up
asp
asp it's got to be done
asp you mean asap nah asp
main that's how quick we need it we
don't have time for more acronyms
distinctly characteristics characters
wait a minute what did i just say it's
the pythagoras site
and what is it called the trench
yeah abu dhabi is in india right
actually if you watch this video too
long you will actually
don't want to get demonetized
not living he edits videos and doesn't
afraid of
anything kids keep using tick tock it
becomes this phenomenal phenomenon
you know what never mind i cannot
phenomenal
phenom phenomenon phenomenon see i know
how to say it phenomenon right i go
for the love of god remind remember this
tweet yes i may have killed her
but that doesn't prove i'm innocent how
did you meet your mama
wait your mama i mean my my ah here i am
trying to innovate god damn it
the word no neglige negligible
i still can't go different yeah that's
that's pretty negative
negligible negligible i can do it holy
got it thank you so i've edited that so
it flows thank you
side view we're supposed to edit so it
flows negligible
magical negligible
this really wouldn't be natured who made
up that word
huh cancel that person can we start
cancel google nature
net shut up you're not shut up
i fear no man but that thing negligible
negligence i'm not even trying to be
funny
it's so hard to say i don't get it wait
what the [ __ ] is this
pewdiepie being the neighbor's i am not
the neighbor's kid
okay baby point prove it
so we keep it light
[Applause]
i want to die
come on this is not neighbor kid
behavior that is weird
i realized i laughed like the joker and
it's making me very uncomfortable
can you believe that people think so
love the way people
embarrass themself ridiculous what oh
the microphone that's not how microphone
okay
[Music]
just laughing at myself this is so
cringe
i'm not the neighbor's kid though
i'm rest my cakes
i've shot a lot of weird videos
[Music]
i have an ar-15 if anyone goes near the
door
i'm gonna okay okay all right that's
enough neighbor kid
dabbing
if you're sad don't be sad just wanted
to wrap it up a little
a little smile on your face so i hope
you enjoyed smash like if you enjoyed
[Music]
and i'll see you guys tomorrow
what the [ __ ] does neighbor's kid mean
someone who's beyond human comprehension
he typically does weird things and has
notes
he does not feel he can hold 36 eggs in
each
yeah i can do that but that does not
make me the neighbor's kid
he's capable of lifting [ __ ] with yeah
i can lift juan
what the [ __ ] is this pewdiepie without
context
never escape my heart
[Applause]
he does not care to see poppy harlow and
you're watching
[Music]
stop hating stop i love everybody
i know where that was from yes oh
that's why you're dumb that's why you
have that dumb ass face that's why
you're a feminist
oh my god what are you wearing oh you
have cat ears wow we're so twinning
i am bored everybody
and i was in a very dark place where is
this place they're going to
the range open your mouth open your
mouth
kiss it i never realized how weird i am
seeing all this
is like what the [ __ ] is wrong with me
dude
you don't see me hey
[Applause]
just gonna click the [ __ ] door oh my
god it's working again
we do the pickle and then he let his
schmeckle go to go to little bit of
pickle
and then he's was in got the paws in and
he took the paws and into balls in
and he turned and put a pickle cyan toes
in and then you get the serotonin
because i am that was [ __ ] bars
though
rare guys i want pewdiepie
season scare pewdiepie season 2
i want it out so bad this is nice and
intimate aren't you enjoying this
oh my god maybe you know what maybe i am
the neighbor's kid i
i'm sorry to see i am starting to
understand what the [ __ ] is this videos
anymore and it's just a good
overall boy in general and hasn't had
any controversy in over
uh but he's wearing a c-shirt week now
i see crush and that means nothing and
he's nasty so
therefore rest my case
pi is basically posting with his career
at this point
what makes you think
used to make so many compilations it's
fun when fans do it
felix and marcia being children what the
[ __ ] does that mean
that's very brave of you was that
sarcasm
[Laughter]
for the ultimate satisfaction how are
you so good
oh your heart kind of sucks cause you've
made it
meaningful okay you're gonna have to
pick my girlfriend i mean my
excuse me are you ready
what is this video i don't remember this
whoa i thought it was gonna go yeah me
too
me too um damn it what's the point
oh no i mean you look cool okay i'm
lying on you
you're pushing me out
look how much fabric
because i got a lot of film i guess you
don't see it
[Laughter]
i'm just literally looking and laughing
at whatever i'm enjoying myself i'm sure
people are too
why are you laughing are we still dating
she says yes i feel awkward how do you
feel
i mean i feel bad for all these people
okay let's just you broke yourself
i mean i watch your videos thank you
they all become like a big blur after a
while
what the [ __ ] what are you saying so you
can always set up so that
i just joined you send me an invitation
and uh
i was chewing they're very chewy those
protein bars
it looks good
[Music]
it's kind of fun to look back on i like
it pewdiepie not realizing it's
unmuted on discord i gotta hit the uh
i gotta hit the report one
no don't follow me oh
oh oh i said that a lot jesus christ
felix
come on how do i still have foreign
[Laughter]
or something all right continue i'm dead
yo let's go feel like you're not muted
killing time
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right dave is my alibi
you're not muted
damn it
well then you know i'm safe god damn it
there's a part two my absolute favorite
thing is jack on mutes to make fun of
him every time
yeah everyone thought i was memeing the
fact that i was unmuted and everyone
actually thought i was imposter
which means everyone actually thinks i'm
that much of an idiot i appreciate that
thank you oh yeah the pokey was supposed
to follow me i did it again
guys watch this
i'm not muted sorry mute the [ __ ] it's
getting worse every time
what oh it's my bad pokey you were
supposed to follow me you [ __ ]
i know but you're not going to the thing
oh
sorry i didn't realize i was muted
[Music]
this is so grinch
oh my god i'm not
i can't even watch it's too cringe god
damn it
only a couple times it happens to the
best of us pewdiepie being the worst
liar
oh no
come back he didn't see it
what the f were you doing are you really
gonna get me
i saw you jumping into the [ __ ] van
you're the one that jumped in the video
oh straight fast feet he freaking killed
it
let's go for felix he's being quiet yeah
you're right you're right
i'll go for grande then
was very suspiciously standing outside
of calms doing nothing because we were
chilling
oh um
what do you mean best liar we were
chilling
so we were chilling that worked
like what tax tasks have you done uh
literally the one that was next to lizzy
i don't know what it's called murder
what do you do what do you do with that
task the laser one
lisa yeah is he's their legal one there
yeah they're even by laser
like the you drag the thing up down left
right
what i i don't listen i don't know how
to explain all the tasks
i just saw a body i reported it
[ __ ] yeah because last time i did
the key one i died right away i'm not
doing it
yeah but why did you pretend to do it
why would i pretend to do it i feel like
so it's it's right at the top of the
house
it's right
[ __ ] all right
all right i'll tell you what happened i
was walking in the corridor
i didn't see anyone and
i just don't understand how you can turn
these
[Laughter]
so we jumped in the vent and jumped out
and then reported the body
listen i don't make the rules
you think it's felix yeah i i would skip
because i'm not really sure
oh i love that
wait what they're having fun in among us
they're not screaming angrily and they
get caught
that's not possible that's funny
bullying his fan base i would never do
that this is the fan art i get
what the hell is that it's like a
hedgehog on my face it's not even
accurate
mars yeah
you are so clever well done
they're complaining this is what they do
they just complain all the time
it's a fun little exercise i bet you
don't have any friends
sorry you have no friends at all i bet
you're
sitting alone i've been collecting
comments secretly
for the past couple of weeks and i
picked the ones that
make you guys seem the dumbest
check this out check this guy out
oh yeah she wore them pewdiepie merch
that's awesome
pewdiepie and cinnamon toast can chaos
[Music]
last time you and your bestie had a
fight never we've never fought we're
fighting right now
you got yourself a girlfriend now guess
what
two can play that game get in here girl
yeah where am i
oh we gotta put a block in the way here
are there no no no
no no no no no no we don't you put it
right here
a minute what you're not
subscribing
don't subscribe needs a beauty bus dare
you not subscribe
you [ __ ] [ __ ] oh god i like all
the [ __ ] videos
get out here stop liking your own videos
this is how it they should have already
been like oh
it hurts oh my dignity
i give you this and i will get this
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh what the [ __ ] take it away why would
you do that
oh that actually made me gag really
oh my god wife why would he do that
why did you do this i thought it was
good
he chewed he chewed and the hamster like
pop stop
clapping at everything
what's that the judges
no no there's no way the judges are
saying unless jack wins the next point
no felix wins oh
judges have spoken bro wait no my joke
judges us booking bruh
[ __ ] they agree
[Laughter]
i'm playing ready boy i'm right you
blink you lose
i have a prepubescent beard well maybe i
just don't want to grow one as long as
yours that makes me look like a
homeless person
did you just roast yourself i did in the
future
well that was me laughing at pewdiepie
videos for a couple minutes
yeah what do you think that guy was that
good did you have a fun time
so it's kind of fun to revisit thanks uh
daniel you're still a chat what the [ __ ]
more proof on why felix was 100 the
neighbor
subscribe for more epic moments and
memories and fun time look at crap
look at the group see you tomorrow guys
you